[Music]
got that good soul in my feet i feel
that hot flap in my body
when it drops
[Music]
this is for clumsy
[Music]
i'm gonna type in high five
[Applause]
thank you for your cooperation good
[Applause]
night
[Music]
oh
and your son took that from me
stole that from me killed that from me
people keep asking if i'm back and i
haven't really had an answer
but now yeah i'm taken on back
and so that she sits patiently waiting
for its next victim
wow this is a terrible
place
i come from the land of the irish spring
dublin's the place where i learned my
thing from the emerald isle to your
place in the hood i'm the man of green
come to do no good
left in the hood come to do no good left
in the hood come to do no good
[Music]
i volunteer as tribute
i believe we have a volunteer
[Music]
jim it's not what it looks like
[Applause]
we're here to solve a mystery
yeah scoob oh why do you want to kill me
i don't want to kill you what would i do
without you
go back to ripping off mob dealers no no
no no you you
complete me
[Applause]
we're gonna make it no why not i don't
think we're gonna make it we're gonna
make it
we're not gonna make it
this is gonna hurt
[Music]
my roof did he make it
i hope he's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
good engagement
[Music]
i've got you you've got me who's got you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i like to move it move it you like to
move it move it
she like to move it move it here
[Applause]
you're under arrest for violating
sections 4153 of the tycho treaty
so hand over whatever galaxy you might
be carrying and step away from your
busted ass vehicle
and put your hands on your head hey now
you're an all-star
get your game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
megatron
[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
oh
oh yes tiny dog we got your friend
advantage me
uh oh just ignore what just happened
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all your love has broken the
curse and freed my soul
i'll never have to kill again really
i'm just screwing with you
i just want to tell you both good luck
we're all counting on
[Music]
[Music]
you don't know what you're saying
you don't want this i want you always
welcome to jurassic park
[Music]
so don't worry
be happy really be happy it has a nice
message
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hi i'm jackie wanna play
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you